in the heart of the balkans
conservationists are fighting to save
what they say
is europe's last free-flowing river from
the headwaters to the mouth
the aos or viosa starts in the mountains
of northern greece sprints into southern
albania and pours into the adriatic
in greece much of the river is a
national park but in albania the
government has plans to dam it for
hydroelectric power
a europe-wide movement is pressing the
albanian government to declare the river
and its tributaries a national park
because this it says is an unparalleled
cradle of biodiversity
there is absolutely no systematic
research being done
so far so we don't even know about the
huge amount of biodiversity what we know
so far
is amazing you know scientists
a few years ago assessed the river in in
one place
only for four days and they found
40 species new to albania and two
species new to science
the conservationist movement recently
won albania's first major
environmental legal victory the
government planned some 40 dams along
the viosa and its tributaries
the first was to be built here at
kalivac flooding the valley behind me
but last september the government
cancelled it on environmental grounds
the consortium building the dam appealed
and in early june
it lost the court case that ruling means
a cascading system of dams down river
also cannot be built at the farming
village of bochem for example
a dam was to go up where this bridge now
stands
this farmer told me the community was
against it and local resistance
seems to have been key to defeating it
there was no public consultation done by
the authorities or by the construction
company
we stressed this point and the court
decided the entire bid process
should be cancelled if you look at when
the government invited competitive bids
and when construction began
it is clear that it was in a great hurry
for the past decade albania has
generated all its electricity from
hydroelectric dams
this gives the country energy autonomy
and its emissions free
but global warming is reducing river
flows and the capacity of dams
conservationists say sun and wind can
provide renewable energy without
destroying habitats
and what makes this habitat unique is
the vios's unfettered freedom to choose
its course
and flood in winter most people they
think
that they know what a river looks like
they have no idea
because we all grew up with channelized
with damned
rivers with diverted rivers albania is
not a wealthy country and aspires to a
european
standard of living but many local
residents see a more lucrative future in
alternative tourism and science than one
based on exploitation of nature
now that they've won a major battle for
that vision they're confident they can
prevail
john cerropolos al jazeera viosa